[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's a very weird
liquid, this.
On the scale of 1 to
10 of weirdness
this comes about 433.
Is it the blood of some strange
machine, you ask?
Do you ask that?
I ask that.
No, it's not.
This stuff is very odd.
It's called a ferrofluid, or a
magnetic liquid, and what's
happening here is there's a
magnet down there and a bolt
in which the magnetic field's
been channelled through.
And the liquid is reacting
to the magnetic field.
That's really odd.
Not many liquids do that.
That's because this liquid has
got tiny nanoparticles,
magnetite, in it.
Now, normally if you put that
kind of particle in a water
solution, it'll just
get ripped out by
the magnetic field.
In this case, it's been coated
with a surfactant, and that
surfactant is an interface
with the water,
which loves the water.
So they're held into the water,
and that makes the
liquid behave as if
it's magnetic.
It's pulled along with the
particles and so it's kind of
channelled into these different
shapes, which are
all defined by the
magnetic field.
So you can confine a liquid with
a magnetic field just by
putting these tiny little
magnetic particles in there.
So nanotechnology, at
its most beautiful.
Car manufactures have used it
because, in a way, what you
can do is you can kind of
confine a liquid and make it
either viscous or quite runny
with just controlling an
electromagnet.
And that means you can make a
car suspension either very
hard or very soft at the
touch of a button.
Now, that sound's like quite a
cool application, I agree,
but, I think, we can come up
with something better.
Although personally, I haven't
yet, except for the bolt.
It's pretty cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]